so thank you very much for inviting me I
first of all like to thank the
organizers especially young for putting
together this program the semester which
is really wonderful and this workshop
has been great I've really really
enjoyed the people and the talks so i
should say my talk today is about a
topic that I we really haven't worked on
so much before in my group and we're
actually what I'm going to talk about
isn't really actually published yet in
fact it's not even submitted yet so and
in fact my title is partly designed to
not reveal the material of the talk
because I wasn't sure would be done in
time so but I think we are and the work
is actually I'm done with my students
and postdocs so the ideal talk about is
sort of the architect is Nicholas break
and he's worked very closely with
breelan Brown and Shannon ricciardi
Shannon mccurdy got married to her work
and while working on this project and so
is carving our honeymoon in Thailand but
brent breelan is in the audience and
nick is in the audience and also other
members of my group angular falcom
starter and boli have also helped us and
contributed to the ideas that i'll talk
about so what I like to talk about the
starting point is like a lot of talks
we've seen today actually is this great
figure from from Carlos's paper showing
PCA of the genotype matrix and reviewing
the geography the geography of the world
and as Iran I'm just said in his thought
this is a surprising result the first
time you see it and and it's quite a
beautiful result I particularly like
this paper not just because it's had a
lot of impact than there's been an
important result but because it's
actually reproducible so
so if you take another data set which
many many people do all the time now
this is sort of the standard tool I'm
going to show you you know if you take
thousand genomes data which we're going
to be talking about in this talk tightly
because it forms the data for the gia
baddest project which is really what I
want to talk about if you take another
data set here there are actually
individuals only from the few places
it's not as refined as the map of Europe
but but you do a PCA and you know you
get a nice clustering actually it turns
out that direct pca on this data set
doesn't it quite the right thing if this
is Africa the yellow or it sexually yeah
this yellowish is Finland purple is
Tuscany and actually Tuscany's between
Finland and Great Britain but i'll tell
you later also how you can actually fix
this but in any case pca clusters
populations and this has been a really
important result so maybe i'll just use
computer so we are curious about a
question that I think as some people
have asked other than us which is what
about expression data so my lab works a
lot of narni seek and we were curious
what if you take the expression matrix
do you see the map of the world and
there's a great data set for trying this
out recently published ivalice data in
tulip elements paper was recently just
published and in it is expression for
462 individuals from LCLs with pretty
decent coverage 30 million reads is not
great but reasonable coverage for RNA
seek for each individual and these this
data is a subset of a thousand genomes
so you actually also have genotype data
for these people and actually the paper
they have only one figure were actually
the labels appear for for where people
are from and it's just showing sort of
this is about what fraction of the
expression is to the splicing
differences or not point being here is
that the paper didn't have an actual
investigation about population structure
in the expression game so
so we were interested in this and so we
took the PCA plot and you get this
picture and it's a bit disappointing you
know it's not really that pretty right
like you don't see Africa and you don't
see the world and you know many people I
think I've actually made this pic chance
of giving up expression is just messy
but we're sort of you know I'm looking
at this if you sort of cross your eyes a
little bit you can see Africa may be
down there so I don't know we wanted
this to work and Nick sort of the idea
that maybe if you rotated your head a
little bit in the high dimensional space
the state isn't this your we're looking
here at expression data we have about in
this analysis we're looking at about
51,000 transcripts so maybe you know
just taking pca it doesn't show you the
geography but maybe if you just tilted
this a little bit maybe you'd see the
geography right okay so i'm going to
show you that in fact expression
contains java that's point of the talk
today it doesn't hear our geography you
don't see it on the pca but it's
actually in there and it's really in
there and it's actually quite
interesting so so i'm going to tilt for
you slow your head and as I'm tilting
your head you're going to see these
expression points start to cluster and
I'm going to get to here where it's not
as pretty as the snips but you have all
the Africans down here fins up here
British here and the Tuskens in the
middle and actually you could probably
tilt you have even a little bit more and
really separate this picture up nicely
okay so what I like to do in today's
talk is tell you how you rotate your
head in 50 1623 dimensions to find this
actual this actual geography and my talk
doesn't have a lot of equations as some
as others have disclosed and I also done
a lot of biology but have some geometry
yes so that's what I'm going to offer
you so to really understand what I'm
going to try to explain I need to start
with the very basics and just revisit
regression for a second and we'll go
build from there so everybody here in
the room has you know taking data and
plotted a line through it part of the
regression line but you know
people sometimes the regression is they
just plug into a formula so there's some
thing with matrices and you just do it
and you do it an R and you get a line
but it's important for this talk to
realize that and everybody here knows
this but but they may not know the
generalizations of this is that you know
regression is actually a sort of
statistical thing you're doing it's not
just that you're actually you know
plugging in into the state but you
actually you know do something Cisco
what you're actually doing is you
actually have a model that's his black
line and you believe that your data is a
linear function of your X values plus
some Gaussian noise right and you're
actually optimizing within that
framework the like lead function to find
the red line yeah that's what you're
actually really doing and the reason I
think this is sort of important is that
a pca which everybody's talking about
here has sort of a bad rap you know
because people when they use it they say
well it's not really statistical you're
not sort of like this thing and you do
it and it works but it turns out you
know it actually is right so so PCA the
way it's usually thought of as sort of a
projection of your points to let you
know to a lower dimension in this case
from 2d to 1d to sort of preserve the
variance of the points that's one way to
look at it and that's actually true
statement but another way to look at it
is this way is that it's actually also
finding a line that maximizes some
likelihood and it's exactly like
regression except here the model is that
the truth is the black line X you know y
is a function of X except that there's
Gaussian noise both in the x axis and in
the y axis right so in regression you
sort of have a perfect data on X and
you're measuring noisy data on why but
in PCA you're measuring noisy data on X
and on why so what I've shown you here
is the regression line where your grass
you know y versus X and then blue is X
versus Y and green is the PCA it's sort
of lies in the middle because you're now
allowing for noise in both axes now it's
a different way to think about it on but
that's sort of a good way to think about
PCA and I didn't come up with this wave
thing you have a PCA this actually sort
of comes from Sam robust maybe some of
you know
Sam Sam and also a Martin Bishop written
about probabilistic PCA and you can sort
of show that there is a I would write it
out here but there's a probabilistic
framework where you see the green line
as not just this projection for
maximizing variance but it's the
statistical way and I want to say one
thing just a message is that everybody
really should be doing PCA in all of
their plots because every sort of data
set we do produce these days actually
has error in the X and the y coordinates
so this is me doing the wrong thing so
this is one of my recent papers on RNA
seek and we were looking at you know our
expression values on Illumina platform
versus solid this is about fixing bias
in RNA seek and we did what everybody
does you know we regressed you know y
versus X it's wrong right because
there's error in our measurements of
expression in X and Y so everybody does
this sort of wrong really everybody
should be using PCA in sort of the
genomics context probably almost every
plot alright so the point of the
probabilistic view of PCA is that it
also offers a nice algorithm and this
algorithm is going to generalize nicely
to what we want to do so the algorithm
is the e/m algorithm so instead of doing
you know there's a linear algebra
expression for PCA you can take the
singular values and all the sort of
stuff but there's a very simple
algorithm for finding PCA language maybe
you haven't thought of before so the
elgen is this you have some points maybe
they're in high dimensional space and
pick a plane in this case a line any
line and the what you know is you're on
this E and I'm step first step is to
project your points onto the line okay
so that's that's the projection onto the
line is actually the estep passerby saw
by this Gaussian model this is your
guess where your hidden data really was
on this line in other ways to think
about this there's a red point here
which stands at the mean of the x and y
values the mean of the data and then
with inner like the pc airline will go
through that point we're gonna let a
toggle around like like a compass you
know like a needle of a compass it's
going to toggle around and what your
entities after you project to the points
you're going to rotate this line so that
the squared distances to the actual
points are minimized but you know these
points on the line are fixed but they're
tethered to the point that got
jected there and so yeah you know you're
no longer have straight lines everything
you imagined these strings tilting and
you're going to find the angle which
minimizes that square there and now you
repeat this once you have this line you
project back down and so you're talking
your line back and forth and that's
actually what PCA is ok so that's sort
of a really nice way I think to think
about PCA and that sort of Sam realizes
algorithm so there's two problems with
this model this is a nice model for data
but the way I presented you can
immediately see that this sort of two
issues one is that there's a Gaussian
assumption in PCA you're actually
assuming at the error you know there's
this true plane that your data is coming
off of your hidden data and you added
Gaussian noise and maybe your data is
not Gaussian in fact as around just
discussed I'll get to this in a second
genotype data is not Gaussian all right
the second thing is that in this model
that I'm sure they showed here you're
assuming that the Gaussian error has the
same magnitude in the two axes that's
the PCA assumption is that in every
coordinate the variance is the same and
that's not true always for data for
example if you think about genotypes
some snips have you know really a lot of
variance and some don't okay so so it's
not a good assumption but they're sort
of ways to deal with that so so actually
pci can be generalized to any member of
exponential family don't have to do the
gaussian and secondly you don't have to
love for equal clearance in each
coordinate and if you don't then you're
doing what's called factor analysis and
just the kind of algorithm i showed you
generalize this directly so there's no
reason to even have this strict
assumption you can allow for different
variants in different coordinates and
you can also allow for a different model
other than the Gaussian so in fact a
really nice paper by Iran that he just
spoke about so that's really perfect I
mean you just showed us this beautiful
movie is in fact doing that so it's a
model-based approach kind of in the way
I would say it is that it's sort of
logistic PCA so what's actually happened
there is that the the Gaussian has been
replaced by Bernoulli random variable
and this has allowed implicitly for
different variants in each coordinate so
it's sort of like factor analysis so
that's actually so it's logistic PC
and it's a very good thing in fact I
wonder where anybody is doing PCA after
his paper everybody should be at least
doing no just a PCA that's better model
so I want to get back to expression and
talk about you know how how we found
this geography sort of from thinking
about these insights and actually that's
another project originated I taught a
class last semester and we talked a lot
about PCA in my class so we were just
thinking about deeply about what this is
about and that's what sort of led us to
this idea I just have to say one thing
before I get there all this you know has
to do with expression data I'm not going
to you know talk about this now them
happy to answer questions later but just
briefly so the jihadist data are you
know it's got 30 million reads per
sample all of this needs to be
quantified and we you know we happen to
do on you seek in my lab so we've
quantified everything with express which
is one of our programs that adam roberts
road and this gives transcript level
isoform level qualification so in all
the sort of remaining material i'm doing
what we're actually looking at is a big
matrix which is individuals by
transcripts multiple transcripts for
gene and we've got an estimate of
expression for each transcript as you
should probably realize that you know
our model for actually estimating
expression includes parameters for
errors in the reeds sequence-specific
bias fragment length distribution in the
prodigal a lot of stuff that makes you
know our NAC complicated you know one
thing we probably need to do and haven't
done yet is investigate how our results
depend on how you call expression i
suspect that if you don't do a good job
because you're not using my software
you're not going to get this good
results okay but look there's you know
it's a lot of noise and expression which
i think makes the results all the more
amazing actually that you actually see
geography and expression data alright
we're interested in expression for his
own sake we're not using it instead of
genotypes for inferring populations oh
no we're actually going to hear some
instead of genotypes for looking at
population structure it's better or
you're gonna make
why I'm gonna make an argument yes I'm
not going to make it on your better or
worse I'm going to make an re me which
is different and I'm Barry we're done in
conjunction with genotype data so okay
so let me like tell you how you might go
about doing so to really speak
expression matrix and then you leave it
kind of abstractly as a big blob and in
this data set we have some individuals
from some geographic locations now when
we r energy is going to do something
canonical like PCA I mean one of the
great things about PCA is it exists
independent of genotype data it's just a
thing you can do to the gate to the
matrix but we tried it didn't work right
so one thing you could do is you could
say okay I mean hm i sentence you know
consuming these populations and we
actually just use for liberty cervix we
just take latitude longitude coordinates
for these things and you can actually
ask for the best projection of your data
until linear space and to a plane that
gives the best correlation with these
points alright see how these points in
high-dimensional space I mean we will
now look for geography we're not just
going to find it okay so you can just
take a projection and smack it down so
that you best correlate with this and
actually if you do that so you're you
take a projection that maximizes the
correlation I should actually say
there's a name for this kind of
projection it's called canonical
correlation analysis and it's also godly
probabilistic framework like PCA that's
are going to be important for us that we
sort of the proposed by Francis bark and
Michael Jordan here but it's really
weird think it's a paper there was never
published it's a tech report and it has
some issues and so it's now it's never
been like work out very nicely but there
is a probabilistic sense in which you
can maximize this correlation in any
case if you were to do this are starting
with the expression matrix you get this
picture ok so there's a lot of
individuals we're actually taking 370
individuals generis was 462 but we only
we threw out the CEUs because they're
all admixed and so on so we wanted a
cleaner picture for now
well if you take all of these big points
and you ask for like the best projection
that shows you the geography well guess
what you find the perfect geography okay
so why did that happen okay so what
you've done is over fit okay so the
thing is right the state is in you know
we have 370 individuals but they're in
fifty thousand dimensional space and
we're allowing ourselves to choose any
plane onto which to project these
individuals to find the geography now
there's a lot of planes in fifty
thousand dimensional space so actually
if you were to shuffle the labels so
that the individuals are not you know
really from where you say they are well
you can still perfectly project them
into the geography which means that well
what's the point of my talk okay so you
can so this is the observation I guess
this is a bad thing my talks gone so
this is the observation okay that if you
take like a tetrahedron right in
three-dimensional space then you know in
this simple example for today right
there only four populations and really
there are three of them form a triangle
and ones in the middle right the Tuscans
are in the convex hull of the fins the
Brits and Africans basically this is
about choosing who is in the middle and
if you think about a tetrahedron with
four colors you can actually choose a
plane to put any one of the of the nodes
in the middle right that's not hard to
see there's just a lot of planes okay so
you can you can sort of and in fact
right if you only have three hundred and
seventy points in fifty thousand
dimensional space they form a simplex so
you can easily just choose a plane that
gives you the perfect geography so
that's not interesting okay so what is
interesting i'm going to argue to you
that what is interesting and that's what
the idea is that if instead of just
going directly from your matrix into the
geography you instead factor it through
a low dimensional projection let's say
using PCA or even better and ron's
logistic pca or even better than that a
model that couples the projection
maximization to this low dimensional
projection if you do that on then maybe
you can actually have an interesting
result because what is this doing well
this
taking the very high dimensional matrix
putting it in low dimension so as to
preserve the variance in the data that's
asking is there still geography here now
if you have 370 points in three
dimensions then it's not clear at all
that you can actually find a plane that
shows you the geography okay so that's
sort of the idea it's very simple idea
okay so so this is the picture I let me
explain out what I was actually showing
you showing you the picture where you
keep 21 dimensions out of your original
51,000 dimensions so you project down to
only 21 dimensions and then you take
that data and you try to correlate it to
geography okay and actually the movie i
showed you before we're simply
increasing this dimension from 23 all
the way up to 21 and that's why the
picture is getting better if you go
flight out to two dimensions you know
you sort of throw out the geography
throw out the baby with the bathwater
but if you want to keep some more pca
you know some more pca dimensions there
then geographies actually in your data
although it's not the predominant signal
that's fine so to convince you that this
is actually meaningful i'm going to show
you what happens if you actually permit
the labels here okay so if you bring me
the labels here you don't see the
geography this is the best correlation
of the low dimensional projection to the
geographic data but after pre-meeting
labels and what that means is basically
that there's actually result here okay
so it's not you know it's not a null
result you're actually seeing something
on trivial in the data all right
um well it's a good question so i can
show you so we can we can do the movie
again so if you if not now you can look
at it again and you can look at the
number two and you can judge for
yourself right so there's two three four
five six seven now already at seven or
eight dimensions you're seeing the
actual geography so oh the permitted
data that's a very good question so in
the premier data you need to be going up
to your maybe around a hundred you start
seeing the geography or 200 yeah i mean
i can actually all i have i have a yeah
yeah it's like it's much higher you need
to go up to like you know maybe up to
two at a hundred you see a much blurrier
picture than this at 20 i mean let's say
yeah let's breelan says maybe go to 200
to see the geography in the primitive
data okay so um so let me just get back
to our was sorry okay bubela so that's
better um okay so the thing is right
that so there's another interesting
thing you can do which is instead of so
you might argue well I mean that's not
so fair I mean you took the geography
you already knew and you glued the
expression data into that geography so
you found it okay big deal but you can
actually do other things so one thing
you can do is instead of going together
the expression data into geography you
can actually glue it into the snip data
directly okay so so the model I'm
proposing here is that we take the
genotype matrix we take the PCA of that
and we find the linear map that provides
the best correlation between these two
house now that's kind of getting
interesting because this Geographic
structure in here I've just shown you
this Geographic structure in here so
maybe the structure actually helps you
know so you have more signal and you can
do that I'm sorry my pictures rotated
here so we really you know how are just
working on this so we don't have so you
have to like turn you have 90 degree
is but this is the picture for the
projection of the expression data and
the two dimensions under a map where
you've tried to produce the best
correlation to a projection of the snip
data so this picture doesn't even know
about geography now it actually does
because we already know that the
genotypes know about geography right so
it's still kind of cheating but it's
sort of you know but it's yep so that's
what it is and I'm sorry this lipid is
projected onto two dimensions but
actually it turns out that we sleep data
you saw better off quite a bit better
off projecting the three dimensions so
the initial picture I showed which have
the swapped Great Britain that that's
fixed if you look into the three PCA so
yeah and again if you shuffle so you do
the same experiments nip vs expression
but shuffling the data there's nothing
okay so you really you know there really
is a geography inside the expression
data now I want to show you another
result which i think is kind of
interesting so we've now found a tilting
of the pc a plane where we have actually
found the geography okay now what we
thought today is this check whether you
know this is sort of generalizable to
have a data set so right and and well
actually before I get to that i'm going
to show you this I'm sorry I'll have
myself um when you have this projection
you can actually ask what is this
projection yeah what genes determine
this projection and what we found is in
the first principal component the
primary contributor is the vitamin D
receptor gene so we were happy right
because vitamin D is a good thing and
this I'm not prepared to say in the talk
because we really have to investigate
this further but it looks like so when
you look at among all genes vitamin D
has the highest correlation with
latitude and none of the snaps around
vitamin D actually produce a geographic
signature so we have seen to have a sort
of independent signature for geography
that sort of really truly expression
base that this is not just the
reflection of the snip affecting the
gene mate
but but we'll have to see in any case
vitamin D is the top of the list and we
have a whole list and it's sort of an
interesting to look at the genes that
are in the first and second principle
work not principle but CCA components
chairman are correlated with the axes
well these axes actually lie in
expression space so you just look at
what are the contributions to the axis
yep just like you might do increase it
just don't want to use cux we started
used your method yeah so there's another
result that kind of like so we did the
following experiment so we took there's
another data set the H GDP data which is
a much larger data set with lot of
individuals to specifically look for
geography as a paper by now Rosenberg
looking at this data and this is his
picture with the pc oxys and we did the
same thing this is our pc picture i
don't have quite the right colors yet
but it's partly on purpose so here you
know all the Africans have been colored
in red but they're actually separate
populations in here every population has
been given its own color and you have to
you can really believe in you that we're
replicating the result because this is a
sort of an upside down l and this is an
inverted l and if you look at it for a
second you'll see that this is actually
africa and this is actually asia and
we're really looking at the same thing
you even see here this double texture
thing appearing here ok so we've that's
the PCA plot for the state but what we
did is we took this plane so this is the
plane for expression data but we have a
duty expression snip analysis or gives
us a plane also for the snip data a
plane that's not the pc a plane and you
can actually take that plane that we
learn from slips and expression together
on geo Venice and put it in here and
that's the that's the projection of the
genotypes and you can just see looking
at this right that you have pulled out
these guys you pulled out these guys you
have this population out and the whole
thing is much more result so there's
sort of a universal projection you're
right we've taken a projection from one
data set where we have expression and we
just used the same plane in another data
set and you can
see more geography okay so I hope that
that would be one of the useful results
what we're doing is that you know
instead of taking each data set up an
issue and just doing PCI on it we should
just learn one good projection from lots
of data and not just expression and
genotype but other phenotype data and
then use that when we're taking your
data sets yes instead of trying to
maximize our nothing to the snip data
Tracy are you minimize the map
interested aw have some other trades say
like red-headed miss you're trying to
maximize your expression great question
you get better thank you yeah so yeah so
I'm well I'm at end of my talk yeah so
then I was ready to talk about today but
the entire motivation has to do
association lapping this right and so
yes so we you can use this model to glue
together phenotype data and exactly the
whole idea is to normalize out the
population structure I'll just say
you're part of the motivation for this
project was the following observation so
if you look at the recent eqtl papers
they have a very bizarre thing going on
so the paper is that you know they're
trying to find Ikki tails and they're
trying to normalize out for geographic
data rather trying to deal with the
structure but in the history of RNA seek
an expression analysis parrot RNA seek
microwaves people would take PCA to
remove artifacts out of the experiment
not geography in association studies
people have been doing PCF for a while
and adding it into the regression as a
covariant or just subtracting out the
residuals so if you go look at the
recent Uchitel papers they come in there
there's sort of this weird thing about
them some of them be pca on the genotype
seven md pcr an expression there's some
this guy would join us towards this
unified picture is that somehow you
should have a sort of symmetry between
what you're doing to the expression what
you're doing to the genotype so that's
exactly what you're kind of asking about
and that's exactly what we're doing with
this yeah so anyway I think I'm possibly
even early so might be the first person
but it's the first time I've given the
talk so i'll just say thank you thanks
down and telling it somehow significant
yeah I mean we don't have a really we
don't ever really so the way you've been
doing it is kind of you know we measure
the correlation versus the correlation
with permutation testing and this is
sort of you know one's going up one's
going on we try to find some of the
sweet spot but I don't think we have a
really solid model selection strategy
that we're really believing it but
that's sort of i've been doing and
that's how you got this number 21
because rather right there you have the
maximum differential between the signal
and the data and the signal in the
permutation test yes no we haven't but
that's the you know something would
definitely they told up how to do the
more research have we got this some of
them slow on is that the right way to do
a QTL then has to do your projection to
the canonical correlation and then
regress on the residuals of that of the
Eugene play yeah so so what you get out
so you know so from this picture you're
going to get a model for your data
that's somehow your no model and there's
many different things you can do with
that so so we have different ideas about
how to use that text we find Ikki tales
like one or one thing you can do is if
you're looking at a specific snip and
expression and you do regression you're
actually asking is that you know
regression significant well you can sort
of asked under this model what
regression coefficient again so under
this sort of null model that you weren't
so use it but nothing but you can also
take out the residuals just like people
who
do any of these things this is one yes
did you try to use partially square
instead of your because that you would
maximize your covariance between
European the expression yeah so so
canonical correlation analysis is
related to partially squares and I don't
have off the top of my head not to
explain exactly the relationship but I
think that what we're doing is somehow
like partially squares actually yeah
this toaster so we've actually generated
some RNA seek data for the HTTP samples
and we do see some PC a clustering of
geography not nearly as well as what you
see using the approach and one of the
concerns that we had had was about
potentially satellite artifacts and all
the differences across the populations
but the extent you're interested happy
to share that yeah sure thanks thanks
Phil example then compare notes yep so
we mentioned the phenotype world were in
dinner combinations in PCA then uses a
period one area where it had been used
not as noise but to clean out the closet
as signal they are polygenic steps
course that have been should have been
described as a signal for a for
association they had you explored any of
these in in this this kind of content we
have an export of it but it's
interesting into the I wanted to just
have side the address a paper that by
August price and vivitrol couple years
ago regardless of higher
the one where we studied judge genetics
and gene expression in african-americans
and that's particularly interesting
because the varying amounts of that
mixture and if you're doing we were
particularly as in trying to estimate
system trans effects and because the SIS
effects will depend only on the local
ancestry you can be confident you're not
missing the cause little sip is not
going to get missed because you're
interested in the answers three
components so I think that's actually
well we were doing with micro arrays and
the other technology was old but I think
I've a sort of interesting we were able
at least on that data the principal
component is readily recovered from the
from the expression data and just
commenting on the previous comment but
because you're looking at a single admix
population you'll probably eliminate an
effective selling artifacts it's wildly
unlikely that the cell line artifact is
going to be correlated with the answer
screen you connect a bunch of
african-american I think it might be
interesting for example to do that on
Hispanics as well I think you get the
three-way fixture some populations that
will give you quite a problem for good
yeah I mean she's asking whether we've
tried sparse pc and that's a very good
question as far as CCA yeah well there's
actually sparse pci and also smart CCA
um yeah so you could do direct spar CCA
off the matrix that's true um no we
haven't done that so so as you go to
your 21 pcs yep and is it that two of
them end up being latitude and longitude
or is that information crime more
dispersed through the my god it's a very
good question and I have the answer
didn't exactly but yeah I don't have a
care but the answer is it's sort of
diffuse it's the vitamin D receptor is
the predominant direction but it's not
yeah it's not directly contended to what
I will tell you that sort of very
interesting in study you can ask the
question how much of the variance is in
the pcas to begin with in genotype
versus expression and the thing is that
expression data has if you for a fixed
number of coordinates there's a lot more
variance in expression PCA than in slip
pca but only small fraction of that is
geographic as opposed to in the snip
case where the majority of the variance
that's captured even though it's less
overall is actually geographic might
that be telling us something that the
signal the geography signal and
expression is not just coming from
genetic differences but it's also coming
from food differences well that's what
I'm saying about vitamin d3 if you think
about it you hear you know in africa vs
europe right the reason you might see
different expression of I'm of the vdr
receptor of I'm d receptor is not
because of your snip but because of your
environment and that's why things really
fascinate about this you know we should
be able to speculate in our but you know
Nick sort of this from Canada and he
would like to go do the Sun people in
Toronto right where they have different
genetic backgrounds before move to the
same place softly
you know we're taking snips and a window
around the vitamin D receptor and
there's no significant association with
latitude compared to random slips in the
journal in that last HTTP pot yes that
was genetic data right yes so what was
aboard their kind of bad parts of the
variation that you were getting rid of
good question i don't have a look into
literally just working on this so yeah
obviously there were excellent questions
so now we have lots of good ideas thank
you any more questions